- C'est un actif extraordinaire.
Puis je peux vous dire que notre
initiative fait l'envie de gens.
- Hydro-Québec a payé le double
du montant qu'avait déboursé
en 2017 la compagnie ArcLight
Capital Partners pour l'achat de
13 centrales hydroélectriques.
La PDG d'Hydro-Québec, Sophie
Brochu, assure que
l'investissement est rentable.
SOPHIE BROCHU, présidente chef
de la direction d'Hydro-Québec
- Cette transaction-là,
financièrement, elle est
significative, mais elle est
ce qu'on appelle "e-creative",
elle crée de la valeur
financis la première
journée de son acquisition.
Donc, c'est un prix tout à fait
correct pour nous
et il va être porteur à travers
les décennies.
- Ces 13 centrales, elles sont
situées sur deux rivières
qui traversent le Vermont,
le New Hampshire
et le Massachusetts.
Les rivières Deerfield
et Connecticut.
Ensemble, leur puissance s'élève
à 589 mégawatts. C'est trois
fois moins que le barrage
de Manic-5, mais assez pourssezr
fournir en électricité 213 000
foyers en Nouvelle-Angleterre.
LOUIS HÉBERT, professeur
de stratégies, HEC Montréal
- C'est comme passer de touriste
à citoyen. C'est en. C'est en. n
exporter, mais un moment donné,
quand c'est un marché qui est
très stratégique, il faut être
capable d'être un citoyen,
d'avoir des activités sur pl
pour des questions de légitimité
et de crédibilité.
- Hydro-Québec soutient avoir
une stratégie commerciale de
partenariat avec les Américains,
plutôt que d'avoir une mainmise
sur leurs installations
hydroélectriques.
tiative qui pourrait
être bénéfique à long terme
pour les Québécois, même
si l'énergie produite demeurera
aux États-Unis.
PIERRE-OLIVIER PINEAU, titulaire
Chaire gestion énergie HEC MTL
- Ce n'est pas à travers
la production énergétique de
ces barrages que les Québécois
vont en tirer profit, mais
c'est à travers la profitabilité
financière que Hydro-Québec va
que les Québécois vont
être servi par cette
transaction.
- Pendant qu'Hydro-Québec
investit à l'étranger, d'autres
projets, comme la construction
de barrages, souhaité par
le premier ministre François
Legault, pourrait prendre forme.
La question est de savoir si la
société d'État aura la capacité
de mener tous ces chantiers
de front. Ici, Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Mon